le tournage d'un clip ça vous amuse
y cultive l'image d'un homme discret et
pudique 11 octobre jean jacques goldman
fête ses 70 ans si le chanteur a dit
adieu à la scène depuis 2004 il reste
toujours aussi populaire auprès des
français
1981 après des débuts difficiles
l'artiste connaît le succès avec son
premier album solo simplement intitulé
georges à goldman à 30 ans le jeune
chanteur fait chavirer les coeurs vous
aviez très fortement envie de rencontrer
jean jacques goldman pourquoi
j'aime beaucoup ses chansons bien sûr et
j'ai eu un déclic pour lui un coup de
foudre comme il ya 20 ans pour eux de
françois de tubes s'enchaînent quand la
musique est bonne comme toi au bout de
mes rêves tous sont des cartons mais le
chanteur refuse d'être une rock star le
tapis rouge les paillettes très peu pour
lui jean jacques goldman veut garder les
pieds sur terre j'ai vécu 30 ans dans
dans l'anonymat
j'étais très heureux d'y être et je
fréquentais des gens qui me plaisait
beaucoup et
j'ai pas du tout l'intention que ça
change
1990 c'est la naissance du trio
fredericks goldman jones
les voici en concert en guyane en 1995
jean jacques goldman a toujours autant
la cote même auprès des plus jeunes
neuf ans plus tard en 2004 clap de fin
pour jean jacques goldman
terminée la scène en solo l'artiste se
fait désormais rare n'apparaît presque
plus en public ni dans l'immédiat sauf
lors des concerts des [ __ ] le voici
en compagnie de maxime le forestier en
2012 tu as bien voulu faire un bal
vénitien on n'est pas muni siens un peu
la banlieue c'est à côté
[Musique]
un an plus tard en 2013 après neuf ans
son concert solo ni album sa popularité
reste intacte jean jacques goldman
devient la personnalité préférée des
français statuettes et en même temps par
rapport à ces actions c'est une belle
personne au total jean jacques goldman a
été élue dix fois personnalité préférée
des français depuis 1981 il a sorti 15
albums et vendu plus de 30 millions de
disques dans le monde
ce
[Musique]